my name's bev buckley
i've been growing vegetables and fruit
for about the last 14 or 15 years
organically and also i teach people how
to do this and we've taught hundreds of
people here on mount tambourine where we
live and also now further much further
afield through internet courses
and one of the things i've found is that
the people
people generally
are very frightened of taking on a new
challenge like growing things we've lost
the we've lost the
the ability
to grow because we've not learned it
from our parents or our grandparents and
this is one of the reasons why books
like annette's
and at wellsford's how to grow healthy
potatoes
is a really really valuable resource
because it teaches you everything you
need to know to grow that crop it
teaches you when to plant
how to plant what fertilizers to use
what sort of pests to look out for that
are going to damage your crops
this is why i really really recommend
that if you're interested in growing
potatoes and of course they're a basic
staple crop that we all need
that you
read and at wellsford's
how to grow healthy potatoes because
that's a really really valuable resource
and it will set your mind at ease and
allow you to do it with confidence